and the problem is we've told women that
we can just have it all yes Queen have
it all you can have the career and still
be treated like a traditional woman and
I think that's where a lot of like
tradcons are are a bit especially the
women are a bit disingenuous because
they pretend they are the Ultimate
Picture Perfect of traditionalism but
really if you didn't get married before
25 you're probably not doesn't mean bad
person
um but now the issue is women want the
best and if we don't get the best then
we somehow find a way to blame the men
and you'll notice in a lot of these
clips they'll they have themes right
it's always the men need to be better
it's never the women need to be better
it's that there aren't enough men to
marry